alors des personnes qu'on aime les
personnes qui j'en avais plein j'en
avais plein de ce qui m'arrive est plein
de choses ces dernières années je ne
vais pas mais quand je vais quand même
quand même prendre mes enfants en fait
parce que j'ai deux enfants formidables
tristan je suis fier de toi tu fais tout
ce que je ne fais pas tu travaille bien
à l'école tu fais des études de chimie
tu m'a scotché donc tu m'aides à tous
les jours hatton à tenir debout et à me
battre pour vous audrey tu fais aussi
des études formidables et je t'aime ma
fille malgré le temps de parcours je
t'aime beaucoup et je veux que tu
continues aussi tes études en ce moment
je vous vois pas beaucoup parce que je
pars très tôt je rentrais tard mais on
va prendre du temps ensemble et voilà je
voulais juste dire à mes enfants que je
vous aime très très fort ah les gens me
mathieu et après j'aurais dû l'être pour
ce que j'écris un poème mai ah oui oui
patrie allez-y
après on fera jour mis à l'essai mais
mais moi je pleure vite mais il est pour
mon ami jean me ayé but parce que c'est
vraiment un emmy j'existe alors c'est
ridicule cher jean mi une poésie à mon
niveau littéraire c'est dire si ces
faibles sans me juger dès le début dans
tpm paix tu m'as accepter ta culture tu
as eu un peu me l'inculquer chaque
semaine c'est toi c'est avec des sushis
qu'on a dîné c'est vrai quand j'ai pété
un plomb seul toit savait me calmer
quand j'étais triste les dernières dans
ta chambre d'amis un lit tu dépliait de
mes amis aujourd'hui et puis le pilier
alors merci d'être mon meilleur ami et
pas que dans tpm p
hama
vous adorez cette séquence lan fait
plaisir cette séquence est prêt mais
tellement merveilleux qui dévalorise
dans l'émission ils font faisant croire
qu'il est radin qui n'est pas sensible
accès à naître qui est tout en
sensibilité que je les adore évidemment